and so it goes the u.s. uses military
action to right the wrongs of its past
military actions this time to stop the
advance of Isis the small group of
killers with the ability to do terrible
harm but is there another way
perhaps here are four alternatives to
bombing Isis it is in the national
security interests of the United States
to respond to the Assad regime's use of
chemical weapons through a targeted
military strike sure there was that
close call a year ago but the US has
stopped short of intervening directly in
Syria until now with Isis Obama is
actually helping the very guy he wants
gone that is awkward
even though at the same time the u.s. is
dishing out more dough to the acceptable
Syria rebels problem is those acceptable
or moderate rebels aren't such a solid
group and not all the rebels are homies
with Uncle Sam
the bigger issue the Syrian conflict
will not be resolved on the battlefield
that's what this guy told the UN earlier
in September he says the reason Isis has
gotten so strong if the international
community has been sleeping on the
Syrian conflict let's go back to Iraq
where Isis hails from one reason it's
been able to gain influence is because
the Iraqi government has little
corruption and dividing people have been
its specialties it is Shia and has
persecuted Sunnis pushing some toward
the extremes of Isis the new prime
minister haider al-abadi has promised to
address these divisions but the proof
has yet to be seen
in the meantime corruption in the Shia
Sunni divide has made the Iraqi army
weak it's mostly Shia very disorganized
and has shown it rather retreat than
diet Isis's hands instead of this hot
mess maybe the US should make good on
its promise and promote real democracy
Isis's be wealthiest terrorist group in
history and its members are well paid
initially it got funds from wealthy
individual donors in Gulf states who are
throwing money at anyone who might get
rid of Assad it also has a knack for
robbing banks but now it gets its cash
from selling oil from the fields it has
control over we're talking two million
dollars a day
it controls 60
syria's oil and sells it to smugglers
from Turkey and even right back to the
Syrian government itself the group also
deals arms collects ransoms from
kidnappings and uses extortion to make
even more money but if no one bought
their oil or paid their ransoms Isis's
strength could run dry u.s. bombing may
stop Isis for now but it could end up
putting more quarters into the
whack-a-mole game known as the war on
terror so why not play a different game
diplomacy diplomacy in the region means
bringing everyone to the table yes
everyone and not just to talk war but
everything we just went over cutting
funding and weapons helping Iraq get it
together and negotiating an end to the
Syrian civil war add to that
humanitarian aid for Syrian refugees and
maybe just maybe you've got yourself a
plan that doesn't require blowing things
up what do you think one more download
the agent plus mobile app and join the
conversation
available in your App Store now